three years ago the City of Seattle
voted to gradually raised its minimum
wage to $15 an hour in the name of human
decency and basic fairness several
cities including New York and Los
Angeles have done the same thing
critics argue that boosting wages by
bureaucratic dicta leads to fewer hours
and jobs for low-income and low-skilled
workers now what the Washington Post
calls a very credible study from
researchers at the University of
Washington finds that the critics are
right the post calls this bad news for
liberals but the real victims are
low-skilled workers the study finds that
when wages were increased to $13
employers cut hours by 9% that means
that low-skilled workers saw their
monthly compensation decrease by an
average of a hundred and twenty-five
dollars studies that downplay the effect
of minimum wage hike have mostly focused
on teenagers and fast-food workers but
the University of Washington paper looks
at the impact on workers spanning all
industries and worker demographics the
findings may surprise progressives who
think that the only limit to higher pay
for workers is the greed and selfishness
of business owners because the Walton
family refuses to provide the wages and
benefits their workers deserve but it
doesn't come as a surprise to people who
remain unconvinced that the law of
supply and demand can be amended by City
Council's
[Applause]
labor is simply another cost for any
business and when the price of something
goes up we tend to buy less of it
another takeaway from the study is that
if you want to raise the income of
low-skilled workers taxpayers should pay
for that burden through direct cash
payments or other forms of welfare
offloading the cost to employers has
unintended consequences even though it's
a lot easier to demonize business owners
for being greedy cheapskates than to
build a consensus around raising taxes
the lesson from Seattle that all cities
should pay attention to is that forcing
businesses to pay more hurts the very
people minimum wage hikes are supposed
to help that such ordinances are usually
passed in the name of low income low
skilled workers only makes that reality
all the worse
[Music]
you
[Music]